seguimos hablando de fútbol porque aquí
en Colombia se disputa el suramericano
sub-20 para analizar este torneo
Contamos con la presencia de Sara Castro
directora de deportes de Caracol radio y
del diario as Colombia bienvenida Sara
Hola Juan buenas noches un gusto como
siempre Sara aquí podemos destacar antes
de analizar a cada selección Cuál es la
importancia de ese tipo de torneos a
nivel regional pues lo primero es que
este es un torneo que lleva más de 70
años de historia O sea que podemos
entender el arraigo que tiene la región
pero lo segundo tiene que ver con la
formación de jugadores básicamente lo
que pasa en este tipo de eventos es que
estos jugadores tienen un momento para
poner a prueba todo eso que han
aprendido en estos años digamos en su
paso por las juveniles o en las
categorías inferiores de sus equipos
estamos hablando que estos jugadores
reciben herramientas tácticas técnicas
emocionales para la gestión de lo que
significa ser un jugador profesional
José pekerman decía además que como hay
muchos jugadores que no llegan a ser
profesionales básicamente lo que se
tiene que hacer aquí es formar personas
Porque muchos de ellos van a quedar
descartados por el sistema entonces aquí
vemos la relevancia de cómo estos
jugadores se ponen a prueba y ponen a
prueba todos esos criterios en cuanto a
la disciplina en cuanto a la formación
que sin duda van a ser fundamentales a
la hora de que ellos pasen a dar digamos
esos pasos adicionales en su carrera y
para un continente exportador como es
latinoamérica esta esta parte del
continente exportador de jugadores es
fundamental porque lo que ganan estos
jugadores es visibilidad digamos que
muchos minutos en campo lo que hacen que
tanto sus clubes como las elecciones de
mayores se vean beneficiadas de este
proceso y además particularmente esta
edición del suramericano ofrece cuatro
plazas directas al mundial sub-20 que
tenemos este mismo año y tres a los
Juegos Panamericanos vamos a empezar a
hablar un poco de las elecciones tenemos
en el hex final a Brasil a Uruguay a
Paraguay a Chile Colombia y a Venezuela
no está Argentina La gran ausente
Argentina dirigida por Javier mascherano
Qué pasó con esa selección albiceleste
sin dudas Una gran sorpresa después de
Brasil Argentina es el equipo de
conmebol con más participaciones en
torneos sub-20 en mundiales sub-20 con
16 han estado en 16 oportunidades allí y
a ver si hablamos de los futbolístico yo
creo que hay tres puntos que son
fundamentales uno que se cometieron
errores individuales graves que costaron
partidos la segunda es que el equipo no
encontró variantes ofensivas y la
tercera es que tuvo una posesión sin
mucha profundidad Pero esto nos lleva un
análisis aún digamos más más profundo y
esto tiene que ver con la elección de
Javier mascherano como el entrenador de
esta selección Porque si bien la
selección de mayores campeona del mundo
tiene un estilo y una identidad mucho
más de juego funcional en torno a la
pelota de sociedades digamos mucho más
cercanas en el campo lo que quiso
implementar Javier mascherano también
por su formación era juego más
posicional que lo que llevó es que a la
selección argentina No encontrara ese
estilo de juego que sin duda tiene que
ver más con esa calidad de jugadores que
tiene y que se vio reflejada en los
resultados que tuvieron en la cancha
entonces seguramente Chiqui Tapia el
presidente de la afa de la federación
argentina de fútbol tiene mucho que
revisar Aunque hoy lo respaldó pero sin
duda es lo que tiene que ver con
selecciones juveniles La idea es que
haya una idea una cultura de juego que
puede implementarse a lo largo de estas
categorías para que sin duda pueda tener
digamos esa influencia en la selección
de mayores qué otra selección de las
seis que están clasificadas podemos
destacar qué equipo te ha llamado la
atención para mí Brasil siempre es el
gran candidato por la cantidad de
talento y de jugadores diferenciales
jugadores también con minutos en equipos
profesionales Colombia está en ascenso
pero yo quiero destacar dos que no están
en la baraja habitualmente Bueno uno sí
que es Uruguay pero el otro es Paraguay
Paraguay viene de ser campeón en los
juegos odesur en la categoría y esto
digamos que de un proyecto que por lo
menos en cuanto a los resultados va
teniendo una solidez importante Paraguay
es un equipo que esa identidad la
encuentra en un juego que no necesita la
posesión que sabe cerrar muy bien los
espacios que prioriza el orden defensivo
y con transiciones es como le hace daño
a sus rivales Y eso también es
interesante porque hay diferentes
estilos de juego en la región el jugador
a seguir ahí es el 10 que es Matías
Segovia pero sin duda lo que lo que
interesa mucho Aquí es la solidez de un
equipo muy muy contundente en su área
defendiendo el área propia y luego
siendo muy efectivo aunque no necesita
tener la posesión y el otro es Uruguay
sin duda el líder del grupo diez puntos
este es también es un equipo que llamó
la atención porque es un es un equipo
que presiona alto de esto da fe chile
que que digamos que por esa vía no tuvo
oportunidades ante el equipo uruguayo es
un equipo también con muy poca posesión
pero con digamos con una capacidad de
definir el partido en situaciones muy
específicas entonces hablamos otra vez
de una identidad de Uruguay que empieza
a recuperarse después de un mundial
difícil en la selección de mayores
Franco González también el jugador
número diez es el que con muy pocas
oportunidades sabe dirigir el espacio se
mueve muy bien detrás del nueve Entonces
vamos a ver un hexagonal muy interesante
aquí en la ciudad de